5 12 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about a team of junior
high school kids winning a state
championship where most of the
competitions in high school
this is the g bots a robotics team from
the word of life christian academy in
northwest las vegas
[Applause]
the state championship in reno earlier
this month was the culmination of months
of hard work
that started with designing a robot so
you got them both tight
then not only the painstaking work of
building it as a team i'm asking him but
also programming it to successfully play
the first tech challenge the machine has
to pick up those yellow blocks carry and
drop them on any of the three trays in
the tower scoring points for doing it
successfully and then doing the same
thing over and over in several matches
to win the championship
as competitive as these young scientist
engineers are they never forget the
mantra of the program
gracious professionalism
in the pit area where students work on
glitches that pop up you'll always see
teams helping each other out with pieces
parts and creative suggestions
and you can help the g bots as they try
to raise 25 000 to send all nine team
members their parents and two coaches to
the world championships in houston next
month
thanks to the g bots coach jim hadley
one of the team moms darcy for
everything they've already done for the
five seventh graders three eighth
graders and one ninth grader that are
the gbos and we got that link to the
donation page on our website eight
newsnow dot com if you know something
that's cool at school let us know uh
cool at school is under the community
tab at eightnewsnow.com or
emailworkschool at school at
eightnewsnow.com i'll tell you what
those wow junior high school kids are
already thinking about their futures as
engineers
and they beat the high school teams yes
they did go g-bots yes fantastic